i was in miami and then i found out that
my money was
was um
i don't want to talk too much about that
but let's just say i know what kind of
money i have unfortunately i only have
two dollars
and nothing else wendy williams is
opening up about her financial situation
i only have two dollars
and nothing else
everything is um
frozen some people are involved with
this and so that's what i'm doing right
now yeah it's a shocking claim from the
daytime tv host during her instagram
live chat with fat joe but for fans who
have been following wendy's journey her
allegation may not come as a surprise
please let me have access to my money
this is not right and again this is not
fair that was wendy back in april
sharing the latest on her ongoing battle
with wells fargo the bank alleges that
wendy is an incapacitated person who
needs a guardianship and as a result
they froze her account but wendy she's
fighting back and has filed a
restraining order against wells fargo in
an effort to get back access to her
money lori schiller and wells fargo
have
this
guardianship
petition
about
keeping me away from my money
this is not right
and you know this is not fair
and in her most recent instagram live
wendy responds to the rumors surrounding
her health like the one about her having
alzheimer's people say things like that
like maybe i went because i have the
lymphedema i told you about my about my
feet
um
people say well
uh
i just am ready to go and where is she
where is she where is she i told you
when they when they froze my money and
stopped it they froze my son's
uh stuff as for how wendy's paying her
bills well i know some people who give
me money
for things like if i want the essential
things like um i want to go out to a
restaurant or i want to come over to
your place you know or i want to go over
to whoever you know what i'm saying
madonna if i want if i want madonna to
come over here if i want um anybody you
know what i'm saying but it really is
about my because my family if i don't
have my money then that means that i
don't that i can't do what i always do
i had a lot of money not as much as you
this all follows the news that the wendy
williams show is coming to an end you'll
recall wendy stepped back from the
talker in october amid her ongoing
health issues including her battle with
graves disease and since then she's had
many guest hosts fill in like sherry
shepard who is now getting her own talk
show titled sherry you have heard it
directly from me the sheri show will
premiere this september and while it'll
air during the same time slot wendy
previously had the comedian made it
clear she's not replacing wendy i am
here to tell you that that is not true
because no one can replace the queen
nobody but i do want to give the queen
her for her her props and her flowers
because wendy had a legendary career in
radio and this show was specifically
crafted for her
no one can do this format but wendy but
don't worry wendy is planning her tv
comeback we've got a lot to talk about
in march she opened up to gma about
getting back to work health is very well
and um i actually have had a few
appointments
you know i'm 57 now and i have the mind
and body of a 25 year old i'm very
comfortable you know my partners with
the show everybody's ready give me about
three months i i there are private
things that i have to deal with and then
i'll be ready to come back
and be free and ready to do my thing
[Music]